Nick, Josh, congratulations.
You guys are in the
third and final round
of this competition.
Now, when you came
here, you faced
really tough challenges
that escalated
throughout the first two rounds.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history--
the zhanmadao.
JOSH: Holy [bleep].
This thing is huge.
[music playing]
Today, I got to try and figure
out forging on this blade.
I've never made anything
as big as this before.
So it'll be a unique challenge.
This is what I'm starting
with, a big old piece 5160.
My forge only has
about 18 inches.
And obviously, working on
it a little bit at a time.
Try and keep it simple, make
it something drawn out to size.
This thing is going
to be gigantic.
[bleep] damn.
We've got the length.
It's a good start.
End of day one, I got
the whole plate forged
out to a real rough shape.
Plan for tomorrow is
to get to the quench
by the end of the day.
NICK: Yesterday, I was
able to get the blade
shaped to where I want it.
Now I can get busy
grinding, and hopefully,
by the end of the day,
to get it quenched.
This is going to be a day
filled with attention to detail.
This is the most
nerve wracking part.
This is kind of the
make or break moment.
So get it in the oil, perfect.
I pull it out, [bleep].
I didn't get a curve on it.
I need it to have a
curve on it, because that
will allow it to function
the way it needs to.
I've got to stick
it back in the fire
and I've got to get it quenched.
This is not what I
wanted to have happen.
So here we go again,
quench number two.
It didn't break.
Best off, there's a little
bit of a curve in it.
Day two was an adventure.
Pretty happy with where
I'm sitting right now.
So what I'm hoping
to have done tomorrow
is get the guard fitted up
and be ready for the final day
of fit and finish.
JOSH: Morning of day
two, goal for today
is to get everything
heat treated.
I'm going about everything
I can to try and get as even
as possible, but there we go.
Coming out of the quench is
going to be a real challenge.
So I clamp it down
with some two-by-fours.
The idea here is to help try
and keep it as straight as I can
while it cools.
End of day two, I
have a quenched blade.
So far, so good.
NICK: I'm doing OK.
A little tired.
Coffee and hate, that's
what I'm fueled by.
Just kidding.
Just coffee this morning.
The sword looks phenomenal.
Now I can really start
focusing on the fit and finish.
So I'm going to start
working on my guard.
After a lot of fire
work, I get the guard
bit right up to the shoulders.
It looks perfect.
Now it's time to start
securing everything.
That seam there I'll fill
with a piece of cord,
and then that's going to be
wrapped back to 12 inches.
I've got to finish the handle,
but I'm comfortable that I can
get this blade done tomorrow.
JOSH: Goals for
today are getting
the blade cleaned up
and ground and then
move to working on the handle.
Got the bevel ground in.
Now I'm going to start working
on getting this handle fit up.
I'm going to glue
these two pieces
together, do some sculpting.
I'm actually going to
make it a little bit
smaller than I would, because
I plan on doing a wrap.
Have a little bit of time left.
So start working on
the shape of the guard.
Doing a little fit on the guard.
I'm happy with the
shape, overall.
Tomorrow is going to be
final assembly, glue up,
all that fun stuff.
I'm just glad Will
hasn't shown up so far.
I'm glad there's
no more parameters.
I got plenty of them.
Yeah, that'll work.
Bladesmiths,
welcome to kill test.
Well, your zhanmadaos
aren't pocketknives.
They definitely look very long,
but what kind of lethal damage
can they do?
To find that out, I
will take your weapons,
deliver some slashes and killing
blows on this boar carcass.
Nick, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All right, Nick, let's
talk about your weapon here.
Now, the design you have, I
was expecting a little bit more
of curve.
Because of how
straight your blade,
it feels more like I'm
chopping before I'm drawing.
But as you can
see, it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Josh, your turn.
So are you ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
All right, Josh.
Let's talk about
your blade here.
The balance is good.
And as much as I can
feel the power in there,
I can wield this weapon and
develop some speed and power.
And the curvature
that you have here
does exactly what this kind
of design is meant to do.
Every cut was very
deep on this carcass,
enough to where it cut
all the way through.
And more importantly,
it'll kill.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen.
Welcome to the strength test.
And to test the strength
and overall construction
of your blades, I'll be chopping
into pots and this horse skull.
And remember, gentlemen,
this is not about what
your blades do to the targets.
This is about what those targets
are going to do to your blades.
Nick, you're up.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All right, Nick.
So there's not
really any chipping
or rolling that I can feel.
It's just sort of--
it's lost its fine edge.
Yes, sir.
Most of these weapons have a
bit more of a curve, and this--
it's got about a slight curve
as I could call a curve.
Yes, sir.
It's a very, very flexible
blade, but it did well.
So nicely done.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Josh.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
So, Josh, very well
crafted blade, which I like.
The guard, the
dimensions, the size
and the shape of the handle,
all really beautiful.
Unfortunately though,
we've got some rolling
on the edge of this blade.
You hear that?
Yes.
You put an incredibly
fine edge on this.
And it showed in the
kill test, but not
so good for hitting pots.
It's a great feeling weapon, but
it did take that edge damage.
All right, bladesmiths,
now it's time to find
out how sharp your blades are.
This is the sharpness test,
the dual sandmen slice.
Now, unlike the
strength test, this
is all about what the
edge of your blade
does to these sandmen.
Nick, you're up first.
Ready for this?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
[grunts]
All right, Nick, let's
talk about your blade here.
As you can see, it cut
the arms, cut the legs,
disemboweled the
rice off the torso.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Josh,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
[grunts]
[bleeps] yeah.
All right, Josh,
this is a cutter.
Just a design of it really
lends itself to really draw cut.
The cuts are very deep and
they're very clean when
you're cutting through.
The rolling it took did not
affect its cutting ability.
So overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, the judges'
deliberation is complete.
They've made their
final decision.
The new "Forged in
Fire" champion is--
Josh.
Congratulations.
Nick, your blade
didn't make the cut.
Doug Marcaida is
going to tell you why.
Nick, the zhamandao
was designed to be
a horse slayer or chopper.
The amount of flex you have
in your blade and the lack
of curvature made
it perform less
than that of your competitor.
All right, Nick, at this
time, please leave the Forge.
Come on forward, my friend.
I may not be the "Forged in
Fire" champion, but by no means
do I consider myself a loser.
Congratulations, dude.
The sword that I
made is something
that I am extremely proud of.
And when it came
down to the decision,
today just wasn't my day.
Congratulations, Josh.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
And that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Come on forward and
shake our hands.
I'm the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and I don't even know
what to think right now.
It's something that I can
show my kids that if you put
your mind to something
100%, you can
really accomplish something.